[Musique]
c'est une
microferme où on a plusieurs activités
on fait du maréchage on a un
rucher on a un petit élevage de
poulepondeuse et euh notre particularité
c'est d'avoir essentiellement fait du
maréchage sur but de permaculture en
conversion bio quand on a commencé donc
en 2021 et là est bio on fait tous les
légumes tomates en en saison courgette
aubergin poivron salade betterave enfin
tout tous les légumes alors on en
fait toute l'année en hiver évidemment
c'est les choux les choses comme ça
euh et ensuite on a aussi un champ de
lavande que l'on fait distiler une fois
par an on fait de l'huile essentielle et
de l'eau florale on a des roses de de
Damas on a 50 rosiers que l'on a planté
il y a quelques années et queù on fait
de de de l'eau florale de rose de Damas
et on a pas mal de plantes aussi
médicinales et et et
avergé alors l'huile essentielle c'est
vraiment le l'extrait de la PL que que
l'on fait enfin la distillation le
principe de la distillation c'est de
faire passer de l'eau en vapeur dans les
fleurs et de de de cette vapeur va
passer dans un dans un alambique qui va
refroid dire et l'eau va sortir de
l'autre côté et l'huile étant plus
légère que l'eau ça remonte à la surface
en dessous vous avez l'eau florale et
au-dessus vous avez l'huile essentielle
d'acord et la différence entre un une
eau florale et un hydrola l'hydrola
c'est sur les les la plante sur les
feuilles et l'eau florale c'est les
fleurs alors nos produits on peut les
trouver soit dans notre distributeur qui
est installé Place de la Liberté à à
neeville de poitour là que sur la à
bellefoie en fait euh et puis on a un
site c'est
martinealaferme.fr où l' peut commander
directement et venir chercher soit la
ferme soit je je dépose en drive dans le
distributeur euh je fais des marchés de
producteurs et euh je vais prochainement
commencer le marché de Notre Dame le
samedi matin commencer à à faire des des
des plats végan en fait aussi bien
salade que des des gratins
pour pour mettre au distributeur parce
que je me suis aperçu que bah les gens
aimaient bien justement trouver des
plats tout près et et je pense que ça
peut apporter un plus et j'aime bien en
plus et voilà n'oubliez pas je suis à
deux de chez
[Musique]
vous